this is Anna Navarro on The View yelling
at people as to why they have to support
Biden and Harris because there are no
arguments left
all there is on that side of the aisle
is the constant quest for power so you
can't make a good argument for Biden and
Harris but you can basically bludgeon
people into voting for them and here's
Anna Navarro
I don't know what the hell is wrong with
Democrats listen here's the bottom line
guys
Joe Biden is going to be your nominee
stop talking about how old he is and
Kamala hair is going to be your vice
president so stop fretting stop ringing
your hands and get behind your ticket
because on the other side your
alternative is Donald Trump or Rhonda
Santos so you tell me what you prefer
get behind the geriatric guy who can't
complete a sentence and has taken every
position on everything and lies about
absolutely everything and is clearly not
in charge and the woman who doesn't know
what her job is otherwise you're not a
good Democrat and I would just contrast
that to the way that I've tried to uh
approach what's going on on the
Republican side obviously I am voting
for a republican no matter who it is in
2024 I am voting for them as opposed to
a Democrat right you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
the Democrats have lost their mind but
as I have said to you guys many times I
am going to interview all of the
candidates we're going to try to do them
all in person I am going to treat them
all the same and at the end of the day
if you watching this right now if half
my audience votes for Trump and 30
percent votes for DeSantis and 12
percent votes for Nikki Haley and seven
percent uh votes for somebody else
that'll be just fine but imagine there
are people that tune into the view to be
yelled at over who they're supposed to
vote for if you come to a different
different conclusion than I do that is
just absolutely fine
[Music]
foreign